so I mean what's it like doing uh I mean
doing something that's nonfiction I mean
when you know and Vinny still alive so
I'm sure was he a chance to talk to
himself
yeah then he's still alive you know
there's only 54 like he just retired you
know 15 years ago or something like that
so it's just tells me the kind of story
that that there's the fact that we're
making a movie about it so quick after
he retired but yeah I mean I met him
once I got to prominence
I've gotten to spend more time with him
you know after filming that I did when
we're making we're making man we're just
go and go and go so does it added
pressure to know like hey people know
this story this is something that to me
the pressure wasn't so much like people
know Vinny cause I you know you know
boxing is not as big of a sport as you
know football or you know basketball and
and so what it to me that didn't really
affect me I was like how other people
are gonna see us they know Vinny it was
more like this is a real person's life
this is a guy who you know put so much
into his career and his reputation him
means everything more people are gonna
see this you know then you know the
price you know knew who he was so by
portraying him absolutely this movie's
gonna affect his day-to-day life and
they're gonna see that and be like yeah
that's oh that's who Vinny was and so
that's that's important was that your
actual real mustache or is that yeah
gotta keep that took a long time I can
imagine stupid you get a chance to talk
to Mike and I know he did he did create
obviously you guys have a relationship
yeah I mean my god good relationship I
just hit him up yesterday he's come to
the premiere he's now a member of the
Academy so I feel nothing which it
doesn't - you're my buddy well yeah I
actually finished we were supposed to
film these movies at the same time but I
finished filming mine like right before
he started his because he's got pushed
back and so I was I just knew what he
was gonna get into and so did he and
Mike you know Mike trained you know
trains but all for that so what about
you what was your training my training
well we were both we both got cast in
our movies when we started filming
Fantastic Four so we're all instead of
that
he's he's bulking up and I'm trying to
trim down and it was like an eight month
you know kind of diet workout process
and then I got to train with Darryl
foster Darryl foster trained Sugar Ray
Leonard for 18 years and he really and
not a lot of time I didn't have a lot of
time and not a lot of time he made me
feel comfortable and and that was
comfortable enough to be on camera and
that's you know so important yeah you
know this movie kind of makes you think
about what I was watching it when you're
in that headpiece I started thinking
about texting and driving I started
thinking about a thousand things it
makes you more aware and kind of
broadening that to social issues
shailene woodley just you know you saw
her standing up for the Dakota Pipeline
sure yeah what do you think about that
her standing up and kind of taking that
stance I mean I think that's yeah I you
know that's why I love - Aileen
Schilling is not afraid to her personal
convictions are more important than any
kind of you know social stature that
she's trying to reach cuz she knows by
doing that it's gonna offend a certain
demographic and maybe that demo it's
going to see your movies and she doesn't
care about that stuff and yeah you know
I think if that was happening - you know
I think if we were doing at - you know
military grades or I think if we're
doing that to the burial grounds that we
hold so sacred I think it would be you
know receive a lot more attention and
you just feel for the Native American
community I mean they've they've haven't
had to have had to give up so much
throughout our history and you know it's
unfortunate I'm just as a human being
just the other you know people going
through that and their loved ones and
everything it's just a it's just tough
man it's just unfortunate so